yesterday one day after the shocking fbi
raid on mar-a-lago joe biden's attorney
general merrick garland has come forward
to take responsibility for the
unprecedented attack on the former
president who just so happens to be
biden's chief political rival in 2024
just now the justice department has
filed a motion in the southern district
of florida to unseal a search warrant
and property receipt relating to a court
approved search that the fbi conducted
earlier this week
that search was of premises located in
florida belonging to the former
president faithful adherence to the rule
of law is the bedrock principle of the
justice department
and of our democracy
upholding the rule of law means applying
the law evenly
without fear or favor
under my watch that is precisely what
the justice department is doing federal
law
long-standing department rules and our
ethical obligations
prevent me from providing further
details as to the basis of the search at
this time
there are however certain points i want
you to know
first
i personally approve the decision to
seek a search warrant in this matter let
me address recent unfounded attacks on
the professionalism of the fbi
and justice department agents and
prosecutors
i will not stand by silently when their
integrity is unfairly attacked
merrick garland will not stand by
silently while the integrity of the fbi
and doj leadership is unfairly attacked
how about when it's fairly attacked
unfair
unfounded just to be clear we're talking
about the same doj and fbi that
conspired with the democrats and
fabricated evidence that trump had
colluded with the russians in order to
spy on the trump campaign then later
launched a years-long 32 million dollar
special counsel investigation also based
on nothing to undermine the trump
administration after trump entered
office and then two days ago sent
jack-booted thugs to raid the home of
the current president's predecessor and
chief rival ostensibly to enforce a law
that many other presidents and even
presidential candidates such as hillary
clinton more egregiously have violated
without consequence
that's the doj that's the fbi that we're
not allowed to criticize according to
merrick garland merrick garland the
jilted former federal judge who is now
exacting revenge on his political
enemies because cocaine mitch mcconnell
and the republicans denied him his dream
job on the supreme court
how dare you attack my integrity i'm not
going to attack merrick garland's
integrity or the integrity of the doj
and fbi leadership because that would
imply that they have any integrity to
attack and they do not
they have four years now revealed
themselves to be political hacks whose
job it is to destroy republicans and to
let democrat criminals such as hillary
clinton such as hunter biden we could be
here all day if we kept listing the
names to let them off the hook for
committing more serious crimes than any
of the crimes that they even accuse the
republicans of
in the case of trump
they have revealed themselves as the boy
who cried wolf
accusing trump of all sorts of nonsense
from the fake dossier about the alleged
hooker urine tape you remember that one
that was a doozy to all the other vague
claims of bribes and blackmail and
collusion without ever once producing
the goods no evidence whatsoever just
all sorts of insinuation
these people merit garland in particular
should be ashamed of what they have done
to the rule of law in the united states
and as far as i'm concerned unless the
fbi found severed heads in a freezer at
mar-a-lago
nothing could justify this raid which
unlike donald trump poses a genuine
threat to our democracy
i'm glad you like that clip now we've
hit a million subscribers that's great
we we've got to hit a billion okay i
think that's the the logical next step
i don't know what what kind of trophy
you get for a billion subscribers when
you hit a million you get a gold trophy
i assume you'll get i don't know
kryptonite or something and a billion i
really want to hit it so subscribe like
ring the bell we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]